yeah so like you were talking about
eldering earlier oh and yes being a
massive souls fan
so uh yeah like what what are some games
or some anime or something
i i just love how i just love that it
took us two hours to get to this normal
conversation just to like chill out for
a meal it's been like a intense two-hour
conversation about porn so far
i get it yeah yeah yeah well what are
some like games and anime that you like
or looking forward to or like or just
like in general yeah whatever your other
interests
everything
i like rpgs in general yeah like um
strategy games like um
[Music]
if you played uh valkyrie chronicles oh
yes yes
right now yeah it's a great series yeah
um i mean you're obviously into like
dragon quest and stuff like that yeah um
yeah there's a new dragon quest 3 remake
coming
oh yeah
yeah i want to play that as well
um what else is coming out oh there's a
was it million abyss
action rpg coming out
is there actually yeah yeah
yeah it's action rpg
but i'm always scared of like anime
games because they haven't had the best
like [ __ ] to play but like yeah you know
i'm interested yeah sure what can they
possibly do do you like do you oh so you
like made in the best thing i do
you know what now now that you see it it
makes so much sense
because
because i'm just like damn that
definitely explores some topics that i
don't normally get to see right like
it's like i mean in the business like
some diorno in it right like there's a
lot of torture scenes in there oh god
that definitely makes me feel
uncomfortable yeah definitely
jesus
a lot of sense holy [ __ ] oh yeah what
are like some like standard manga that
you would like recommend all like you
really really like well you know now spy
family is big of course and
i'm more of a manga spy phone guy
um what else is new
[Music]
that was just like the most wholesome
thing
that did surprise me
[Laughter]
i don't know why there's a part of me
that's like spider family to vanilla
yeah
i was expecting to be like yeah so
berserk you know oh he has to be
pinpoint
that [ __ ] just like suffer porn
it's just hilarious to like imagine you
reading spy phone and being like hell
yeah
oh that's so cute
yeah
so so like what's kind of like some of
your favorites of all time then oh my
favorites of all time like anime of
manga or video games
um anything drawn by
about the takashi oh
amazing yeah of course
um anything one by murata is amazing of
course the godly odds man like wait
we're all fanboys and monaco yeah yeah
yeah yeah
like his recent work with like one punch
man especially yeah [ __ ] incredible
and obviously i shield as well i don't i
don't know how that man keeps improving
yeah it's correct like i thought he
peaked at isil21
and then one punch man was like i could
do better
crazy good yeah
oh what's the takashi as well like i
that that's definitely like another one
where i can definitely see like it kind
of like makes sense because like he also
has like a really like you know darkish
style and like you know especially like
some scenes in death note like
back in the day it was like whoa that's
uh this is it this isn't shonen jump
yeah yeah it's like holy [ __ ] yeah like
i definitely remember reading death note
the first time and i just
i i didn't even know it was shonen jump
yeah you know like i knew at that time
what kind of manga was kind of in shonen
jump you know you had like you know you
know dragon balls your
shows you know all that kind of thing
and then you go to death note and you're
like this comes from the same magazine
yeah it looks it looks like a saiyan
yeah it feels like a sane in mind yeah
yeah so it's like yeah i remember like
walls of text right yeah yeah
like a novel hobby i can't imagine
reading it and not having like the
[ __ ] elves theme playing
well that's that's that's how people
experience it before the anime yeah yeah
yeah i know but like now i can't think
about death note without having that
song in my head i know yeah it's so
iconic yeah the anime is so good yeah
because like i remember when i first saw
that being adapted because that was one
of the few mangas i read before watching
the anime and i was just like there's no
way that's going to work in anime form
there is like too much dialogue there's
people who are too stylized
just eating potato chips
[Laughter]
so it like blew my mind that i was just
the anime was just that engrossing where
i just thought there was no way you'd be
able to translate
all of this text going on into an
interesting into an interesting anime
form but they did it but they did it
[ __ ] whoever directed that was like
five head dude like they clearly knew
how to like take text based and just
like very still visuals and make it
visually exciting yeah you also
mentioned you'd put many hours into
elden ring oh yeah but almost 200 i
think jesus christ
yeah i got like 70 hours in it it's so
good yeah boys haven't played it yet for
some reason i don't know why
but it's because i'm trying to find time
to do it because i know i know i've
played enough like like [ __ ] from
software games where i'm like i know i'm
going to love this game yeah but i also
have commitments
as well yeah and i need to like block
out a week from my schedule at least
something is something so amazing about
when that health bar pops up on the
screen
yeah i don't know what it is that gets
me so excited every time like every
single time yeah of course
it's so hard
what a game dude yeah
yeah
what about some video games aside from
eldon ring uh i mean i suppose you've
been playing a lot
of course yeah he's great never played
uh fps games or anything like that well
yeah i've been i played apex like when
it first came out
me too i love apex i played um
i think last battlefield where i played
was three though
oh oh oh battlefield 3. i mean it's been
buggy mess ever since yeah three was
kind of he was like like borderline you
know it's like i could accept this yeah
bad company two was really good that was
a good battlefield game god and you got
okay so you're a gamer good yeah good
he's a gamer yeah he's a gamer he is a
gamer
yeah how much time do you have to like
pursue like your other hobbies outside
of your work because you hear some
horror stories about manga artists just
like having zero time if you're working
like if you're doing a monthly or weekly
then you have no time
i guess you do like bi-monthly right i
do buy monthly but now i'm just like
taking long hiatuses let's see like
because i i bought my i bought a house
i'm like fixing it up regarding this
gardening and doing other retiree things
right
but you know i
want to spend more time drawing
spend more time drawing eye penetration
in the darkest depths
need to get my priorities
that's what a call comes back to baby
all comes back to that yeah